ald
[Silence]
for
shlam
[Silence]
yeah
We are continuing in just a few
chapters of
authored
by
obviously this is and we repeat this
often
because especially for people online and
even on our
Flyers it says that the book that we are
currently going through
is is the book that we've been studying
for the past few years in this class and
we haven't deviated from that we are
just
adding parts that were not as
comprehensive in Z that fall in line
with the spirit of
Z we were discussing the Miracles of the
Prophet s. wasam that were performed by
Allah through
him
as an indicator and as a
proof of the validity and the veracity
of our prophet's claim to
prophethood that every messenger and
Prophet was given miracles to
perform by
which it will be proven without
beyond the shadow of a doubt that this
is indeed a messenger of Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
taala we were in the
section regarding the prophecies
of our Prophet Muhammad s. wasam things
that he informed us would
happen in the future the near future or
the distant
future we
discussed for instance
the prophecy
that would have a long life and he's one
of the last of the companions to pass
away likewise he prophesized
that would
be killed in battle by
the by the incorrect of the two groups
when the fighting occurred
between aam
andq in the time in
and so it came to
pass likewise he informed us that this
nation this the Muslim world the Muslim
body would
separate and it would
become
Schism and disjointed by
Innovation but there will always be a
group that are upon the truth that truth
that Legacy that pure unadulterated
Legacy of Muhammad
Sall would endure until Allah takes back
the
[Silence]
Quran
for
[Silence]
subh to this Fe
Ma
[Silence]
here
another thing that the prophet sallallah
alai wasallam prophesized would
occur is that this
nation would divide and separate and
Schism that this nation would divide as
he prophesies into 73 major
groups there's a narration on the
authority of
mu and others it's a very well-known
narration most of us have probably heard
it it has many different accounts and
chains of
transmission the gist of
which accumulate to his statement
Sall
wasam he
said the
Jews divided into 71
groups and the Christians divided into
groups and this nation of mine shall
divide into 73 groups all of
them in the fire but one the companions
asked which one is that he
said meaning the group upon the
unadulterated Quran and Sunnah in
another wording he said that group which
is upon that which I am upon and my
companions why does this division occur
this division happens because of
innovation Innovation is the
essence of division in Allah subhanahu
waala's
religion
Innovation Allah subhanahu waala sends
down the truth it is clear it is
irrefutable
is
impregnable
and it remains a Guiding Light until man
starts to meddle with it starts to put
in their own ideas their own opinions
and pass it off as
religion when this happens people divide
and that's the nature of
innovation Innovation never starts big
and gets smaller that's not how it works
it starts small an idea an action a
building a structure it starts as
something
small and as time goes on that small
thing is built upon until it turns
into an in some cases an entirely
different
religion some
Innovations proceeded to become so
mutated with time that they became into
they turned into a completely different
religion and there are sects that claim
to be Muslim in our world that have
this for instance
the the
is this is a group which is found more
in
is found more in India Pakistan
these areas
also the areas of of Persian
descent it's a very prominent
meab and they have
beliefs which have become so distorted
over time that it has taken them out of
the fold of Islam they believe they have
their own prophets they have their own
Messengers Allah sends prophets to them
and they worship Graves and all kinds of
things
this did not start this it started
as an idea started as and it continued
to mutate and evolve until it became a
completely different religion and you
can clearly see that in the previous
religions before
us there are groups of Christianity
groups of
Judaism which are so radically departed
from the
original belief beliefs and the
original teachings of Christianity or
Judaism to the point that they're no
longer even part of that
religion if you look for instance at
Catholicism Catholicism is a big
religion but when you look at the
practice of
Catholicism essentially in Catholicism
they worship everything except for Allah
subhanahu wa taala worship Saints they
worship Mary they worship Jesus they
worship St Peter and St Paul and they
pray to them and they have actual Idols
Ina in some cases that they literally
bow down
to and
rever just as idolators do this did not
start this with the da of has said
likewise Christianity modern
Christianity the majority of SE of
christiandom believe in the concept
of the Trinity the Trinity that there is
the Father the Son the Holy Ghost these
three are one
Etc Allah subhanahu wa speaks about this
idea which was less
prominent in the prophet Sall alam's
time he
says
and so this belief of the
Trinity that we have the father we have
the son we have the Holy Ghost this is
the human material incarnation of God
this is the spirit of God and all of
these
ideas this didn't this this became this
was an idea that was just a small idea
that came out of someone's mind many
many years prior
and with time it evolved
into just total
polytheism
idolatry and these things
occur with what with Innovation when we
look at modern
Christianity modern Judaism what are
these things these are evolved
Innovations started as a little thing
and this is why Innovation is so serious
in Islam the Prophet sallallah Al wasam
made it very clear that Innovation is a
major sin it is a grave sin and an
incredible disservice to Islam and to
the legacy of the Prophet
sallallah the religion is complete
doesn't need anybody to add to it or
take away from it or rethink it it's
very clear and so he says s am which
often times he would say in before he
would begin his address
his
in he would say
s the best of guidance or the best of
words are the words of Allah and the
best of guidance and Legacy is that of
Muhammad s. wasam and the worst thing is
innovation those newly invented matters
for indeed every newly invented matter
in the religion is an innovation is a
misguidance and every misguidance is in
the fire this is what he would say newly
invented matter for every newly invented
matter is an innovation and every
Innovation is a
misguidance and every misguidance is in
the fire got
[Silence]
s
and so these Innovations when we look at
them person may say you know what's the
big deal it's just a slight
thing I believe that the prophet Sall
wasam didn't do this but I don't see it
as being a big issue it's just a
statement at a certain time or place
it's just a belief or it's just an
action or a type of worship at a
particular time or a worship in a way
that the prophet Sall alai wasallam did
not do it what's the problem with that
well first of all you are making an
alteration to Allah's religion and no
one has the right to do that except for
Allah even the prophet
s. himself does not have the right to do
that that's the first
issue the second
issue is this will not end here this
will be built upon by the generations
that follow us we are
essentially doing a disservice to the
generations that come after us when we
practice Innovation why because our
generation has a
responsibility in front of
Allah
to pass this religion On to the Next
Generation in the way that we received
it we're supposed to pass it on
unadulterated
unaltered pure as it was when it was
given to us when we
receive that religion of Allah and we
alter it even slightly we pass it on to
those who come after us in an altered
state we were not fulfilling of our
entrustment we our generation is
entrusted with preserving the religion
to pass it on to the next Generation so
that the people who come after us have
an equal opportunity to be guided by
Allah subhanahu waala this is not my
religion it doesn't belong to me I can't
make changes to it it's not my opinion
this is Allah subhanahu waala's
religion and so the prophet Sall wasam
in spite of
this prophesized that there would be
much different in this
nation and that this nation would divide
div into 73 major
sects the difference however is
that there will always be the saved sect
or the delivered
sect as the scholars refer to it and
that is the group which is upon the
Quran and Sunnah we mentioned that this
group is it doesn't necessarily mean
it's a group somewhere all together
collect eled doesn't mean that
necessarily it means that dispersed
throughout the there will be beacons
of light and together collectively they
are a group and this group doesn't have
any particular
name this group doesn't have any this
group is not identified by
name this group is identified by action
and by quality
that they adhere
strictly to the religion of Allah
subhah
[Silence]
waala
what
[Silence]
for
Allah
subh
another of his prophecies is that a fire
would manifest would come out of
the earth and it would be so incredibly
hot and
bright
that the light from this fire would
be seen all the way in Medina in
alz and this fire came out in the land
of Yemen also in Medina itself a fire
similar to this came out this was in the
6th Century it was similar to a volcano
but it was not a
volcano because volcanoes are known to
people for thousands of years it was not
described as a volcano it was described
as a fire that none have no one had ever
seen the likes of before it was
described by a to have come out and to
have run rivers of molten rock that when
it when these rivers of molten rock
would
dry they would become hard as Stone and
gray and very
very hardened and that these
Rivers
flowed for many
weeks and people were very scared and
people repented to Allah subhanahu
waaa and forgave each other and
overlooked disputes all in an attempt to
gain Allah subhanahu waala's mercy and
to be
spared and Allah subhanahu wa tells us
in the Quran we send these
Miracles as a type of in order to
frighten people so that they will wake
up from their Slumber from their
misguidance and return to Allah
subhanahu waala
nothing nothing in the
world removes the human being's argument
and invalidates it like
fear
pure
natural fear
puts all arguments to the side if you
want to know what you really believe who
you really are when you're very afraid
that is usually what who a person really
is because they stop they stop making up
excuses when they're afraid don't
argue Allah subhanahu waala tells us
that the human being is very good at
arguing
that the human being is best and most
plentiful in arguing coming up with
arguments to try to twist the truth to
accommodate them TST twist the truth
into falsehood and twist falsehood and
to make it masquerade as truth that
these arguments are very quickly put
aside when a person is in serious fear
all of these lies that they tell
themselves
they you know are very swiftly
removed and invalidated
by a true
[Silence]
fear
abak
J
[Silence]
another thing that
occurred in the time of
the
companions which the prophet
sallam informed of and
prophesized was
the was the battle
ofama and he informed
thit this narration is collected
by he said
to one of the companions he said you
will live a very fulfilling
meaningful life and you will be martyred
you'll have a very meaningful death very
meaningful Shah that you will be
martyred in the way of
Allah and he lived a very fruitful and
blessed life and he
was martyred in the Battle of
aama which was a battle that took place
in the time of Abu Bakr
when the battles
of apostasy took place throughout the
Arab peninsula in parts of
[Silence]
Yemen
had
[Silence]
they Allah subhah
waala
[Silence]
for
Med sallallah
wasam likewise another of his prophecies
that is mentioned in B and
Muslim tells us that the prophet
s said
to that you will be of the people of
paradise But first you will have a
great Tri
ation that you will have to endure in
this
life
and as he said so it came to
pass was
martyred and was killed in Cold Blood
as Theif of the Muslim by a group of
insurgents
[Silence]
Muslim
was
[Silence]
l
another of the Prophet Sall alam's
prophecies was regarding a man that's
the companions were
very very Amazed by they were
very impressed by this man 's Valor
during the Battle
of this man was very courageous he was
it seemed he had no fear he fought
very
valiantly and so when he
was in the battle the prophet sallallah
alai wasam of course he's he's not
necessarily in the front lines he's at
the you know at the camp at the camp
while the battle is going on the battle
of
was not a short Battle Battle of K was
very long
weeks and they informed the prophet
sallallah alai wasam of this man and his
Valor and how courageous he was and how
valiantly he was fighting and the
prophet sallallah alai wasallam said
this man is going to be of the people of
the fire this was amazing to
them however this was a
prophecy and he was injured during one
of his
skirmishes and the injury was very
painful and he killed himself he
committed suicide and it was as the
prophet
sallallah
informed
[Silence]
the
another of his prophecies is an
incident that happened it's transmitted
by IM Ahmed collected by he by IM Ahmed
and
others
that who came to ask the prophet
sallam about the nature
of good and Merit and the nature of sin
what is evil what is good in essence and
when he came the prophet sallallah alai
wasam said I Fe I you have come to ask
about Good and Evil so he informed him
of his question before he even
asked
[Silence]
Muslim
can
[Silence]
s
can
[Silence]
s
Med
[Silence]
when
s
[Silence]
om
for
[Silence]
we
will stop there for this evening we
reached the story
of which is another of the prophets
prophecies Salam it's an important story
it's a story that we can derive a lot of
lessons from we'd to speak about it
in more detail we have run out of
sufficient time to be a able to discuss
this incident in in further
detail and so inshallah we will pick up
there next week with the story
of and the prophecy of
this information that was given to the
people of Mecca before the conquest of
Mecca from someone who was informing
about the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam plans we will stop
[Silence]
there